au moment de se dire au revoir encore
nombreux sont les voyageurs qui affirme
en chemin avoir été entraîné dans le
tourbillon des retards et des
annulations pourront toujours partir
avant 6 1% à la barcelone finalement ben
notre vol est annulé on nous on a quitté
de vancouver le veulent et est direct à
ottawa il a été annulé non modifiées
autre vol j'ai pris trois vols pour
arriver à montréal et si air canada qui
a supprimé 154 vol de son horaire cet
été on demande aux clients pénalisés de
s'occuper eux-mêmes du remplacement de
leur billet d'avion
[Musique]
voire à la rue port de montréal la
situation s'est quelque peu améliorée
selon certains membres du personnel mais
les files sont très impressionnantes
encore et de nombreux voyageurs la
disent vivre carrément un cas state or
la charte canadienne des droits des
passagers aériens permet aux voyageurs
de réclamer des compensations
financières
allant entre 400 et 1000 dollars en
raison de retards et annulations de 1800
dollars en cas de surréservation et 2400
$ pour des bagages perdus ou retardés
mais pour y parvenir il faut faire la
démonstration que la faute revient bel
et bien aux transporteurs bien qu'elle
doit annuler des vols bien que des
places à bord des avions on sait très
bien que présentement il ya des
problèmes d'équipages y manque de
pilotes et membres d'équipage il manque
de personnel dans un rapport et si la
compagnie aérienne visés ne rembourse
pas son client dans les 30 jours comme
la loi le prescrit c'est l'office des
transports du canada qui doit examiner
les dossiers où l'attend s'étire jusqu'à
un an et demi